Die SV Elversberg mischen auch nach dem 0-0 gegen den HSV weiter im Aufstiegsrennen der 2. Bundesliga mit. Wohin soll es denn jetzt noch gehen? Der Karlsruher SC hingegen versumpft immer mehr im Tabellen-Niemannsland der Liga und blickt bereits auf einen kommenden Umbruch im Sommer. Darüber spreche ich jetzt in diesem Zweitligaschwerpunkt mit Journalist Marc Drumm vom SR und KSC-Experte Jörn Kreuzer. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, wäre lang genug für Geli Landgraf. Marc Grapf, Martin Farka.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Klar, er kann mit diesen Aussagen auch irgendwie seinen eigenen Wert unterstreichen, den Verein so ein bisschen kitzeln. Denn man sieht ja auch, allein wenn man auf die ausgegebenen Ablösen guckt und ähnliches, der KSC macht dahingehend keine großen Sprünge und stagniert dahingehend in dieser 2. Liga und wird von Team SV Elversberg und Co. vielleicht sogar eher überholt in Zukunft. Da kann so ein junger, ambitionierter Trainer schon sagen, Leute, ihr habt mich, dann lasst doch jetzt hier was aufbauen. Und mit solchen Aussagen kann man das natürlich ein bisschen herauskitzeln. Dass man sagen kann, ich kann auch woanders zur Not. Das macht einen Lukas Kwasniok auch bloß ein bisschen rumpeliger, sage ich mal.
Ja, und im Endeffekt, um das zu Ende zu bringen, nur einen Satz dazu. Im Endeffekt war das aber auch seine ganze, also die Argumentationslinie ist nicht neu. Das war im Endeffekt auch die ganze Zeit die Argumentationslinie während der Vertragsverhandlungen, die ja sich sehr lang gezogen haben. Also von daher ist es jetzt kein neuer Stand. Aber er wurde halt drauf angesprochen, dann sagt er was dazu. Klar.
Genau, genau. Ist mir halt jetzt erst untergekommen, wenn man nicht jeden Tag dran ist, dann horcht man da schon mal auf. Ein vielleicht noch viel, viel größeres Fragezeichen. Du hast schon das Jubiläum genannt. Die Nachfolge von Kreuzer. Das Amt des Geschäftsführers Sport ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren unbesetzt. Wieso? Also die erste Frage, wieso gelang es denn überhaupt nicht, diese Lücke bislang zu schließen? Das ist ja die erste interessante Frage.
Naja, und jetzt dreh ich mal den Spieß rum. Man muss sich überhaupt überlegen, ob bis vor kurzem das eben als Lücke in dem Sinn kommuniziert wurde. Da muss man ja auch mal ehrlich sein. Die haben quasi in Juni 2023– also erst hieß es, wir schmeißen den Kreuzer raus. Wir haben eigentlich die Eier legende Wollmichsau gesucht de facto. Es sollen TV-Gelder her, es sollen Spieler her, die Geld bringen und überhaupt soll man sportlich wieder Erfolg haben. Also es kann kein Sportdirektor der Welt quasi mit den Voraussetzungen, die man in Karlsruhe hat oder generell in der 2. Liga. Also das ist sehr schwierig, perspektivisch glaube ich. Und dann hat man gesagt, ja, man geht in so einen professionellen Prozess. Das ist, wie gesagt, stand vor zwei Jahren und plötzlich im Juni gab es ein Kandidat mit mutmaßlich Carsten Rotenbach, der hier im NLZ bei St. Pauli unterwegs ist. Gab es eine Indiskretion der Zeitung bzw. es wurde durchgesteckt an den Medien und dann hat Carsten Rotenbach wohl abgesagt damals im Juni vor zwei Jahren. Und dann hat der KSC aber eine neue Struktur erst mal präsentiert und hat gesagt, okay, Michael Becker, der eigentlich für die Wirtschaftlichkeit am Start ist als Geschäftsleiter, der ist quasi der starke Mann beim KSC und der hat drei Bereichsleiter unter sich. Und dann wurde erst im August 2023 Sebastian Freis als Bereichsleiter Profis gewissermaßen installiert. Und jeder weiß, wer Sportdirektoren kennt und mit denen schon zu tun hatte, weiß ganz genau, dass kein Sportdirektor mit Format, sage ich mal, ich will Sebastian Freis das Format nicht absprechen, aber keiner macht Bereichsleiter. Der will gleichberechtigt neben dem wirtschaftlichen Chef sein gewissermaßen. Und da war das gar kein Thema. Und jetzt hat der Präsident vor kurzem von den Mitgliedern darauf angesprochen, gesagt, ja, vor einem Jahr haben sie wieder angefangen, den Sportchef zu suchen. Also doch jetzt, oder wie? Und das Thema wird jetzt immer heißer, sage ich mal. Und was dazu kommt ist halt auch, das war mir gar nicht so bewusst bis vor kurzem, Sebastian Freys Vertrag läuft aus im Sommer. Das bedeutet, du suchst jetzt offiziell wieder einen Sportchef auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite macht der, der eigentlich die Transfers machen soll, läuft der Vertrag aus. Und das finde ich tatsächlich, dieses Vakuum können wir uns eigentlich nicht leisten. Mal gucken.
Thema Vorgriff auf den Sommer, Thema langfristige Kaderplanung. Definitiv. Du hast gesagt, es wird konkreter. Medien berichten, dass Olaf Rebbe, der zuletzt bei Nürnberg gehen musste, hoch im Kurs stehen soll. Auch Ex-HSVler Ralf Becker ist im Gespräch. Was für ein Profil braucht der Club deiner Meinung nach denn auf dieser Rolle?
Ich glaube, es kann nur einer werden, der quasi die Vorgaben erfüllen kann oder erfüllen will, die der Verein jetzt vor zwei Jahren gegeben hat. Weil es gab ja schon Strategiewechsel mit diesem, wir setzen mehr auf jüngere Spieler. Das sieht man glaube ich auch im letzten Sommer. Das sind vor allem Perspektivspieler, was ja auch ein Stück weit ein Gamble ist. Und der ist jetzt im letzten Winter nicht so richtig, im letzten Sommer nicht so richtig aufgegangen. Das auf jeden Fall. Und ja, also ich könnte mir schon, deshalb wundert es mich jetzt beispielsweise nicht, dass Olaf Rebbel so in der Verlosung ist, weil der konnte sich quasi sich profilieren mit der Geschichte jetzt in Nürnberg, wo er unfassbar viel Transfererlöse quasi erzeugt hat durch die Spieler, die er dort holte. Und im Endeffekt soll diese Vision weitergeführt werden, dass man eher auf die entwicklungsfähigen Spieler setzt, die Kohle reinbringen, dass man guckt, dass zwischen MLZ und Profimannschaft das weiterhin durchlässig bleibt beispielsweise. Aber es wird auch immer wieder betont, dass man einen Stamm zusammen hat, der das dann trägt. Und machen wir uns nichts vor, der Stamm ist auch endlich bei uns. Marvin Warnizek ist auch über 30 mittlerweile. Und von daher werden die Aufgaben auf den Sportchef zukommen, auf den neuen. Und schnellstmöglich braucht diese Mannschaft im Sommer so ein bisschen frischen Wind.
Da sind wir dann nämlich bei der dritten Baustelle der Mannschaft. Es laufen im Sommer immens viele Verträge aus, unter anderem von Christoph Kobalt, Leon Jensen, Robin Baumuth. Leon Jensen soll ja auch der Wechsel nach Berlin, die Rückkehr zu Hertha bevorstehen heißt es. Bei vielen Spielern weiß man nicht, wie lange die Verträge noch laufen. Da ist es nicht genau kommuniziert, habe ich nachgeguckt. Und dazu kommen ja aber auch zahlreiche Leinen, die enden werden. Das heißt, es steht am Ende des Tages ein riesiger Umbruch an. Wo soll denn die Reise dahin gehen? Welche Vision hat der KSC für den Kader? Du hast ja schon gesagt, es soll mehr in Richtung junge, entwicklungsfähige Spieler gehen, die für Profit gehen können. Aber ja, jetzt ist aktuell sogar die Frage, wer baut diesen Kader überhaupt? Also, wo setzt man da überhaupt an? Also, ich finde, das ist gerade ein großes Wirrwarr.
Ja, und das ist halt vor allem auch eine spannende Frage, weil man ja sich tatsächlich auch in den letzten Jahren wirtschaftlich konsolidiert hat. Deshalb werden natürlich auch die Stimmen laut, die sagen, man muss so ein bisschen mehr in den Kader investieren. Weil ich finde schon, dass der letzte Sommer so extrem aus Perspektive gebaut wird. Und ich glaube halt schon, dass man Spieler braucht, die direkt funktionieren und helfen auf jeden Fall. Es sind zumindest zwei oder drei. Und darum kann man eben auch noch mal jüngere Spieler bauen. Dass man ja auch nie vergessen darf, die Spieler, die im letzten Sommer geholt wurden, die können ja irgendwann schon noch funktionieren. Manchmal klappt das ja auch erst in der zweiten Saison. Die können rangeführt werden. Ich glaube, der Robin Häuser, der wird uns nächste Saison enorm helfen. Der war bis zum 10. Spieltag raus und geht jetzt so langsam auf, sag ich mal, gewöhnt sich vielleicht an Eichner und so weiter oder ans neue Umfeld.
Das kann schon sein und David Herold ist ja auch noch sehr jung, der Linksverteidiger.
Genau, aber da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, was die ganze Kaderplanung wieder zerschießen kann, dass so Leute wie Herold Beifuß oder auch Max Weiß, der jetzt im Tor steht, direkt wieder im Sommer Verkaufskandidaten sein werden. Das definitiv. Max Weiß zum Beispiel ist der Torwart in der zweiten Liga, der mit Abstand den größten Marktwert hat. Der ist 3 Millionen wert laut Transfermarkt, wenn man das so als Einordnung mal nehmen will. Und tatsächlich wird er jetzt auch nicht seit gestern erst mit Wolfsburg in Verbindung gebracht. Von daher steht ein eigengewächstes Tor nach einem Jahr direkt wieder weg, so nach dem Motto. Beifuß hat sich geweigert, seinen Zertrag zu verlängern. Den müsste man dann wahrscheinlich auch ins Schaufenster stellen und so weiter. Also sprich, Leute, auf die du gesetzt hast, sind möglicherweise auch im Sommer wieder weg. Das wäre quasi eine weitere Baustelle bei den Transferbemühungen. Und deshalb war meine Hoffnung, und da wäre ich dann schon enttäuscht, wenn das nicht so kommen würde, dass der neue Sportchef dann tatsächlich das Geld, das man durch Budo, Zivci, Waze und so weiter eingenommen hat, auch im Sommer mal ein bisschen investiert. Weil es hieß tatsächlich auch bei dieser Neuausrichtung, dass alles, was im Sport generiert wird, auch wieder in den Sport reinfließen wird. Das hat Michael Becker extra noch mal gesagt. Und dann, ich kann die Entscheidung, die strategische, total nachvollziehen, dass man sagt, wir ersetzen den Budo durch ein Leihgeschäft, bringen die Saison vernünftig zu Ende. Aber dann möchte ich aber auch im Sommer so ein bisschen, ja, also was heißt, ein bisschen was sehen. Aber ich mache mir langsam Sorgen, weil tatsächlich habe ich so das Gefühl, dass der Kader sich zurückentwickelt ein bisschen. Dafür spricht ja auch die aktuelle Tabellenplatzierung mit Platz 7, Platz 5 in den letzten Jahren. Das wird es definitiv nicht dieses Jahr. Also im Sommer muss sich definitiv was tun.
Definitiv. Es bleiben ja gar nicht so viele Korsettstange. Also klar, Marcel Franke durfte bleiben, so ein Nikolaj Rapp durfte bleiben, Marwin Warnizek sowieso und vorne vielleicht so ein Fabian Schleusener.
Der hat noch Vertrag, genau.
Der hat noch Vertrag. Ich glaube, Sebastian Jung auch?
Sebastian Jungs Vertrag wurde verlängert und das muss man sich auch mal überlegen, dass wirklich einer mit den konstantesten… Also Sebastian Jung ist so ein super Kicker. Marwin Warnizek, da können wir echt froh sein, dass der seine gesundheitlichen Probleme in den Griff bekommen hat. Der wird auch bleiben. Aber Jahrgang 90. Achso.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Okay, tja. Ich glaube, das schreit einfach nach noch einem Treffen hier beim KSC im Rasenfunk, weil wir jetzt, glaube ich, eher einfach offen gelegt haben, wie viele Fragezeichen es in diesem Verein gibt, die man jetzt gar nicht mit Gewissheit beantworten kann. Aber eine potenzielle vierte Baustelle, wenn du zu Gast bist, muss ich natürlich abfragen. Gibt es Neues aus dem Haus auf Karlsruhe? Oder ist es in den Gremien zur Abwechslung mal ein bisschen ruhiger?
Nö, zurzeit ist es ein bisschen ruhig. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es jederzeit da mit Sportdirektor-Entscheidungen und so wieder ein bisschen aufploppt. Also vorerst, die letzten Ausläufer waren vielleicht so die Sache mit Jérôme Gondorff, der plötzlich geklagt hat, dass sein Vertrag sich doch angeblich verlängert hätte und so weiter.
Das habe ich mitbekommen.
Ja, und es wurde dann irgendwie abgeschmettert, weil alle gesagt haben, ja, nee, es ist einfach ausgelaufen. Und da ist er jetzt ja auch öffentlichkeitswirksam in einem Interview zu Kreuzer gekocht. Das war so das Spannendste, was so abseits des Rasens, sage ich mal, zu diesem House of Karlsruhe in letzter Zeit passiert ist. Und ich glaube schon, dass es schon damit zu tun hatte, ein Stück weit.
Dann dadurch, dass wir nicht wissen, wo die Reise genau hingeht, möchte ich mir von dir eine Utopie bauen lassen. Was wäre denn für dich, wenn also quasi Sommer 2026, die quasi nächste Saison ist gespielt, die alle Personalien sind entschieden, was müsste passieren, dass du sagst, das war ein erfolgreiches Jahr, jetzt gehen wir wieder mit Perspektive in die nächsten Jahre. Was muss dafür in der Saison auf den Schaltpositionen, in den Gremien und so weiter passiert sein unter dem Kader?
Naja, also ideal fände ich, wenn sie ihn jetzt schon holen wollen, fände ich natürlich erstmal einen Sportchat super, der dann quasi auch erkennbar erste Dinge in die Wege geleitet hat, dass man beispielsweise einen Spielertyp wie Mantanowicz mal 2-3 Jahre halten kann, wie zuletzt Philipp Hoffmann, der war ja schon einige Zeit da, bevor der nach Bochum ist, dass man da halt auch irgendwie eine klare Tendenz erkennt und dass möglicherweise auch junge Spieler auch ein, zwei Jahre erstmal nochmal durchziehen, damit irgendwie zumindest die Mannschaft, damit man auch das Gespür bekommt, die Mannschaft geht wieder quasi in eine gute Richtung, in Anführungszeichen. Also ich würde jetzt sagen, es ist noch nicht entschieden, in welche Richtung es geht, aber aktuell birgt die Situation durchaus Gefahren, dass es quasi doch wieder in eine andere Richtung gehen kann, wo man dachte eigentlich ist immer da weg. Das würde ich mir sehr wünschen.
Ich finde ja, es gibt ein paar echt spannende Talente beim KSC. Max Weiß, wie gesagt, muss man gucken, ob der nicht den Verein direkt wieder verlässt. Aber ich habe ja jetzt auch Ben Verhard in Berlin gesehen. Ich finde, das war noch mit der auffälligste, der ja auch eine gute Chance hatte. Oder auch, wie du gesagt hast, Pinto Pedrosa auf rechts, aber ja auch glaube ich ein aktuell verletzter Schiller Roklu. Der ist ja auch nicht ganz verkehrt, glaube ich. Also dahingehend passiert ja wieder mehr. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass so aus der U23 und U19 vor allem vom KSC wieder mehr produziert wird. Das war eine Zeit lang gefühlt auch, naja, weniger zumindest.
Und da habe ich natürlich ein letztes Saisonhighlight, das habe ich komplett vergessen, wenn du schon die U19 ansprichst. Pokalfinale am 23.05. in Potsdam gegen Werder Bremen. Da freue ich mich drauf, werde ich auch hinfahren.
Schau an, schau an. Schön, im Schalem von Turbine dann, oder?
Wo findet das statt? Ja, genau, Babelswerk da.
Ja, nett. Ja, nett. Ja, da schaue ich vielleicht da auch vorbei. Das klingt ja eigentlich ganz glanzig.
Hol mal ein Pokal endlich mal wieder.
Was war der letzte Titel? Die Drittligameisterschaft? Ist man damals überhaupt noch im Aufstieg Meister geworden?
Ja, ich glaube, ja. Einmal ist man Meister geworden, aber wir haben das Halbmasters in den 90ern gewonnen und davor zweimal Pokal im 50ern.
Ich sehe es. Die deutsche Drittligameisterschaft 2012, 2013 war der letzte Titel. Was war der letzte Titel in Elversberg, Marc?
Die sind ja gar nicht so lange her. Drittliga-Aufstieg, 2. Liga-Aufstieg, erst das zweite Jahr 2. Liga. Dann gibt es noch diverse Saarland-Pokalsiege, die sie eine Reihe feiern durften, bevor sie in die 2. Liga aufgestiegen sind. Also, wir müssen nicht so viel, wir können doch nicht in die 50er zurückgehen, weil da gab es das nicht so. Also, die jüngsten Erfolge sind tatsächlich dann die beiden Aufstiege in Serie. Plus, es waren, glaube ich, jeweils Dubelsiege, also jeweils Pokalsiege noch dazu.
Verstehe. Gut, dann machen wir diese Sendung doch rund und schauen. Und ich bedanke mich an dieser Stelle bei Jörn Kreuzer und Marc Drumm für eure Zeit. Das hat ganz großen Spaß gemacht. Ich habe sehr viel gelernt, besonders natürlich über Elversberg. Das ist ja manchmal noch ein bisschen unbeschriebeneres Blatt als der KSC, den man ja schon gut kennt. Vielen lieben Dank an euch beide.
Total gern. Vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Und ansonsten bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch zu sagen, unterstützt diesen Podcast sehr gerne, rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Schaut in die Kontoumstellung. Show notes, ganz wichtig. Und dann hören wir uns das nächste Mal, ja, in vielleicht sogar schon zwei Wochen. Wer weiß, übernimmt Eva, übernehme ich. Wir werden es sehen. Macht's gut und eine schöne Restwoche. Bis dann.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.